à paris la place de la république était
samuel elle était prof et elle était
charny leur voix rassemblés pour lutter
contre la noirceur et caricatures de
mahomet publiées par charlie hebdo
flottait omniprésente au dessus des
têtes rassemblés en masse pour la
liberté d'expression et la laïcité
samuel pâtit les avaient montré que ces
caricatures à ses élèves
peu de temps avant d'être décapités pas
le but des dessins est quand même
compliquée pour ça ça ça nous sommes son
corps dans la foule
la cinéaste nadia el fani qui a déjà été
la cible des islamistes
si aujourd'hui on s'attaque à un
professeur de cette façon c'est que plus
rien ne va à corps il est vraiment temps
de réagir vraiment en deux de plus que
résister ce fait ça fait des années
qu'on hurle
malgré la présence de nombreuses
personnalités politiques dans tous les
rassemblements organisés partout en
france
aujourd'hui la parole et citoyenne prend
de grands discours des dirigeants cela
se feront plus tôt ce mercredi lors d'un
hommage national organisé à la mémoire
de samuel pâtit
amélie elle commence tout juste sa
carrière de professeur d'histoire
géographie comme samuel patil a fait
pendant toutes ces années il lui revient
de veiller ses élèves à la liberté de
penser et de s'exprimer
je continuerai de montrer des
caricatures je continuerai deck temps
d'expliquer ce que c'est que la liberté
d'expression la liberté de presse la
liberté de pensée la liberté de culte la
liberté de religion
toutes les libertés je continuerai à les
enseigner à expliquer pourquoi elles
sont importantes et pourquoi c'est le
fondement de notre société en france non
j'appelle à une minute de silence ne pas
se censurer en cherchant comment peut
bien se remettre du choc qui touche ici
droite aux tripes ici marie ève bédard
radio-canada paris